ding ding ding all right hello everybody
I'm International Orbiter Michael J
comer and this is winning with chess
psychology now before I was an
administrative guy I had many successes
in my chest career do you think I got
all good by studying and you know reen
test books anything like that no right
you know I stirred in I sure did I had
to use my mind and you play mind games
so I'm going to go over a game from two
years ago it was the Saturday night
special December 2017 so as an organizer
I decided to schedule this a nice
special when all the grandmasters were
at the Pan Am's okay so all the kids
from Webster all the slew grandmasters
they were they were nowhere to be found
and there's 18 hundred dollars cash
unconditionally guaranteed up for grabs
so you know I put myself in this thing
all right so there's one Grandmaster in
the tournament Oxshott Chandra and of
course our pal world champion national
master Julian Pro LICO of the protest
League Fame of course I'm the world
champion manager and I got the Rings to
prove it yeah so anyhow so they're in
the tournament so they're the top two
dogs so it's a four round event game 15
plus two second increment just like the
protest week so so I know I'm gonna play
like scrub in round one nish all odda
probably around two so easy win so then
brown three shucks I might have to be
paired up against somebody like that
so what do I do I take a strategic round
three 1/2 point by all right so I'm to a
No
and so now I got the half point okay and
now if San odd would win his game if you
so nod it's basically I'm going to be
playing for second place is $400 and I
would be paired up against the nod and
put me against the nod $400 in the
middle I'm gonna take it every day of
the week all right
so unfortunately sanad could not be WCM
iris ow shucks well that kind of foiled
that plan so now Julian has three points
ha-cha-cha Andra has three points
Alex Marlar who I am paired with has two
points along with a big crop of field
with two points and of course I have two
and a half points so basically here's
the situation
if I win my match against Alex I'll
finish with three and a half if Julian
draws a shot or loses it doesn't matter
we're gonna all split four hundred
dollars okay so if I beat Alex bottom
line no matter what I get four hundred
dollars if I would draw Alex I would get
like third place money seventy-five
bucks or something now Alex Marlar has
to beat me cuz if Alex Marlar draws me
okay he'll he'll be on a prize
contention okay so you have to know what
your opponents mindset is going in so if
Alex Marlar draws like Julian all he has
three points oxides got three points and
I'll have three points because I'll have
to draw inhale up two and a half so
there's no way in the world he would
ever agree to a draw got everybody got
that I already have my by only 1/2 point
by available so here it is I got the
black pieces but I'm going to pretend
like I'm going for the draw all right so
here we go
so Alex starts out d4 d6
alright so ii 5 hoping that he takes
but he's smarter than that so i take he
takes night attacks the knight will he
take it
no it develops his knight i attack his
pawn well Julian what do you think about
that move I put a question mark by it
yeah so it's attacking my deep on that's
protected four different ways or
something so right so I develop it
brings out his queen I'm like take my
bishop he does all right so now Castle
so he's obviously going for a win here
right he does not want to draw a draw
he's got no money okay so now I play a
little aggressive but that's about as
aggressive as I'm gonna get
so now he puts his bishop on this long
diagonal so so he's got threats of like
'if I've and so forth so I get my rook
off the diagonal nice going for me g4
Knight up five okay so he's attacking my
knight so I attack his Queen
counter-attack
he moves this quaint so my knight is
still under attack I think the computer
actually wants me to just give it up but
I'm going back home
okay I'm going home I'm going home so he
takes I take he attacks me I retreat so
this this type control is game 15 + 2
second increment now in the protest
League that - second increment really
comes into play because you're playing
on the internet you can pre move and
everything but in reality when you're in
that time scramble yet 2 seconds doesn't
help you at all unless you have a big
winning position so alex is on the
attack and I'm just making simple moves
like look at my pieces they're all back
there so I'm making my moves rather
quickly and he's really thinking how am
I going to beat him so he is down
extensively on time alright so he's
going for it g5 and now I'm like okay
this is how I'm gonna win he's gonna get
under a minute and blunder and I win
okay
so that's that's my goal sir rook c8
that I like it so he attacks my knight I
better protect it but by protecting it
what did I leave undefended oh jeez
that's adjourned the d6 pawn now now I
honestly think about resigning but for
how long do you think I think about
resigning 0.2 0.2 seconds I'm like get
that garbage out of here come on we got
the plan to win right just get them
under a minute and get them alright so
something like alright and and I'm like
hey you know a few moves ago look at
look at how bad my knight was right
that's why the computer wanted me just
just get get rid of it just get on with
the show but now you know you got to
look on the positives
there's not many positives in this
position but hey my nights out he's in a
pin but he's out alright and maybe I can
Castle right
alright so Knight attacks the pin P so I
take it takes it so alright so what am i
attacking don't say anything it let's
let the little the littlest guys alright
feelings how do you know that but
luckily I wasn't playing you cuz he's
like you want my bishop wait til my rook
says something about it and then good
old checkmate yeah so just this I so
just as I foresaw he got under a minute
he blundered I won $400 and way to go
now this was not the first time I
actually played Alex Marlar
can you believe it yes okay alright so
so I took a long long layoff of chess in
the mid 2000s so so I come back you know
am i studying am i reading
no no but I've got I've got the will to
win and I've got some imagination let's
say so so I'm I come back after a long
layoff and I'm on board one like like
nobody's any good you know I've got I
got I got it down so now I get paired
I'm like a 1,600 here and I get paired
against 1800 Alex Marlar at this point I
have no idea who he is
however he looks like my cousin Matt and
guess what every time I play my cousin
Matt checkmate all right so so I've got
the psychological out on Alex cuz he
might think he's hot stuff 1,800 but in
my mind I'm thinking he's like a 400 at
best all right so believe it or not I
had many successes as a child and the
most one was chess life 1998 you're
gonna hear a lot about 1998 in this
lecture alright so there is a published
author dragon Cecilia Michael J comer
st. Louis Missouri so there's no
mistakes okay what's your opinion of
beef or c5 Knight f3 knight c6 d for
Bishop g7 Bishop III Queen b6 and they
accelerated dragon alright this this is
the comer variation Queen to b6 right
here and what does the UH what does the
guy say Grand Master Larry Evans
it looks risky a critical line is 95
Queen a5 check Bishop d2 or c3 Queen d8
night b5 with initiative and somehow
this 1800 kid that looks like my cousin
figures it out alright
so he got maybe he reads just life and
knew exactly who I was all right so what
what do I do here so I don't want to get
forked right so play work b8 he checks
me but I got his be pawn so I'm looking
up in the world
so the game goes and it's you know it's
a fight I get the pin on he protects it
just keep piling on the pin pieces get
the big check get another check I got
another check I'm out of checks all
right all right so I have attacking the
F pawn he protects it and get his Jeep
on he gets my B pawn rook takes okay so
now I'm like oh man I don't know what to
do it's just gonna be a draw it looks
like I have four pawns to two but he's
got a massive massive threat of rook C
to c7 is there anything I can do I'm
gonna hide while you think about it all
right
people at home you figure it out I want
to hear from the man in the orange all
right Brooke a where did where do you
want work a to go cuz you got the right
piece you're touching the right piece
right now check it's a check there's
better you can do something even better
with that rook do you kind of have your
hand up or not nearly and then the kind
of hand
all right adjourned yeah rook f2 and
then if he plays down here guess what I
take and now I'm protecting the big dude
I'm protecting the yeah protecting the F
pawn but I can't find it so I just like
let's just draw whatever
alright call it a day so I want some
money in that tournament but that was a
lot of fun so believe in a net we can do
that on the international stage so we
just hosted the GM I am st. Louis
Invitational in which our homegrown
talent world champion of the protest
Liga Julian Pro LICO participated
unfortunately Julian got off to a not so
hot start but I gave him a piece of
advice and he put the Pro and Pro LICO
so if anybody knows
good old Owen old bidding yeah so anyway
he's a well I guess I should say he's a
thirteen hundred that it's a true
thirteen hundred let's just say and
anyway
Julian's opponent Yuri creakin looks
very similar to Owen so I was like oh
and just pretend you're playing you're
Julian pretend Creon is Owen and you'll
have no difficulties at all so so how do
you think this game ends up pretty good
huh so big check and now what is this
the game alright this is the game this
is like we're alive now Julian admitted
to me that when he played c6 he was
thinking there that looks like an O and
move for sure
alright so gave him some confidence and
now this kid really plays like Owen like
like what would you play in this
position so I just played Bishop g5
what's the threat yeah right so what
should you play if you're a normal
player yes yeah if I was playing I would
play Bishop e7 what's my bishop doing on
this diagonal anyway Wow
it's like biting at nails right it's
protected two different ways so he just
lets his King get destroyed double
isolated pawns and now Julian's on the
attack and notice Julian doesn't throw
in this worthless check very good Julian
but at least he waited for it he's like
maybe this move maybe this move but he
finally did it it had a point
check them yeah always check right and
now Julia it's got to get some monster
checks in here big check and now this
this is when the game really turns is
now obviously after Queen takes Queen
check you can't take with the King
because 96 coming in but guess what 96
is coming in anyway and one of your
pawns is gonna fall obviously if I
played b6 I'll just remove the defender
obviously just remove the defender
anyway but I won't perform and now
Julian is really good he's got this
night just on a beautiful square just
dominating this worthless Bishop and
it's protecting everything big check
just to show them who's boss
that rook attacks the pawn oh oh oh
nothing can can you find Julian's move
to seal the deal yeah Felix alright yeah
you might get checked
oh the sandwich kid all right now yeah
but you do like moving that rook huh
all right yeah well at least you don't
get checked anybody and I guess I guess
join it you might be the best kid in the
house all right so the threat is rook
takes f3 check do we want that to happen
yeah anyway I'm a river creaking but who
else we got here all right Felix with
guest number 2 beautiful all right and
now you get to king on e4 and it's very
convenient because that's where the
white winning white pieces go on the dgt
board so once he played king e4 he
instead of moving the king he just put
his king on d5 and called it a day right
kind of all right well that's my story
and I'm sticking to it
alright so so good for Julian so Julian
got the win and now jazz in my game
against Alex Marlar
you got to know the situation of your
your standings and of your opponents so
Talia
W Steph am fed wfm I am W I am
Talia servantes was playing in a I am
norm tournament and anyway so in order
to get an IM norm
she needed like six and a half points
she had four and a half points going
into what
the penultimate round round eight of
nine so she needed two wins and her last
two games she was paired against
international master international
master in a lot of these tournaments
there's no 30 move draw rule and there's
a lot of quick quick draws as you'll see
it and momentarily but Talia's opponent
didn't know what the score was or
anything so you just sat down played a
few moves off or draw and thought you
just laughed at him and proceeded like
no I'm going for an IM tournament
annoying so good for Talia she beat the
I am of course she did not get the I am
north so into this tournament
this guy Titus had six points needed six
and a half to clinch as I am North sorry
his circle inches Grandmaster title
North so Steven circus round nine
opponent comes up to me before after
round eight before round nine and was
like hey what's the deal how many points
as tight just need to become get as jim
north and i'm like a half and jerks like
great I can just go party at the chess
house all night long and not have to
study cuz look at how this game goes it
doesn't matter who's who would you like
a draw yeah I'm a grandmaster good I'm
going back to bed alright so so that's
why you need to know the tournament
situations at all times so look who else
knew the tournament situations
we're going back to November 1998
this is the last US not just any class
championship this is the u.s. class
championship all right so I'm for know
and I'm paired against the other guy for
know what do you think's gonna happen
like take a look at this one
yep up no more moves JEP draw no I got
my name in chest
Life magazine all right you're gonna
show that Danny just life all right good
[Laughter]
all right all right so we all know about
the tournament situations now so let's
go back so that's we're in 1998 let's
stay in 1998 we live the good old days
all right
so I am playing in the state
championship February 28 1998 so in
order to become the state champion which
is my ultimate goal you have to go for
know if you get a draw just forget about
it okay so we're gonna speed through the
game I'm white we're gonna get to this
ending here all right so now we have a
rook endgame okay I'm white I'm up upon
and Anna and the guys in check so it's
all falling apart for him
all right so should I castle in this
position no yeah make your king of
warrior in the end game even a journals
dead right all right so yeah you want to
trade fine
so I'm up a pawn in an endgame right but
I'm going to make a very very silly move
here oh so what should black play here
Alex goooo
do you want to be state champion Ayrton
tink oh yeah
always check okay how hard is it alright
so he checked me and now my nemesis
his father is watching the game and he's
like oh just draw draw
so I was like the guy's biggest
competition and so let's see should I
just call it a day
no II six to the rescue you don't have
to calculate out anything it's just I
gotta go for the win right can he do it
is it gonna be fast enough uh-oh it
looks like he's gonna Queen first should
I be afraid no cuz it's check another
check and now I knew he was gonna play
this move what move do you think he
plays yes check have you ever heard of a
thing called the cross-check boom game
over
alright so so alright so that was round
two of four I got a very easy round in
round three and now I get to play my
nemesis in round four this is for the
state title everybody all right so can t
prevail so I had the white pieces again
I got the white pieces against the the
tough people so that was very nice of me
or of the director all right so to speed
through remember so so there was a
rushing guy just like maybe he's Eric
ting chango's cousin Andre right before
in November 97 get this so I thought wow
it's like me and this guy with the hat
we're gonna we're gonna face off for the
championship but then Andre moves the
Joplin Missouri anybody heard Joplin
Missouri we got some fans in Joplin
Missouri hello anyway there's nothing
wrong with Joplin
but he moves to Joplin he's like the
ringer and he's like I want to be state
champion too it's like now so anyway but
I'm like I'm gonna win because I beat
this the defending champion I'm gonna be
state champion so that's that's what my
my plan is at least so this is not very
good for me I don't know how I'm gonna
win and now this is the critical point
he gets the a eight file I'm doomed so
he's gonna give me a big check I do not
like to be checked but sometimes it's
inevitable sorry
so now he's threatening to take my
bishops and a pen rook takes rook takes
check so I got to do some maneuvering
lower maneuvering more but we're both
oblivious to it too a check totally
oblivious and why do I play this move
it's beyond me so what move can he just
play to laugh at me Rick takes c4
I'm never gonna be state champion thanks
a lot of childhood
oh but check he finally sees the check
now do you think I'm like check no cuz
that's not psychology right right and
this is winning with chess psychology so
so if let's just say blacks King is on
h8 what move would black play instantly
this is from 1998 Dennis I'm just about
ready to beat the defending state
champion he doesn't realize he's in
check always yeah everybody know how
much the King is worth that or he does
know nine billion points right so you
think you would know where your nine
billion point pieces and what's
attacking them at all times so what
would what would black play if his King
was mysteriously on h8
nope yes No
so here he is
comer I'm coming to get your rook sorry
Robert touchmove buddy
you know where you have to put it boom
right there so I take and now my nerves
are like at an all-time high here I take
and so now look it plays Julien's bill
he's like he's like he's got his hat on
he's like I'm wonder turd I'm still
gonna come back and beat your chick so
now winning with says psychology all I'm
saying right now keep yourself in the
pin keep yourself in the pin keep
yourself in the pin so guess what he
flees and then this is the time to slam
your piece oh yeah
so he's in the pen so he takes takes and
now you know okay he's got one guy that
can beat you still so just yeah get him
off the board and then game over
all right so that's how I became 1998
stay chess champion so if anybody talks
about 1998 that's what I am referring to
all right so we still got a couple games
left yeah we've got a couple of games
left ever because Dennis just showed up
we got a game or two so you've got to
know your your opponent's mindset so
this is a game I played on the eve of
the Superbowl Rams against the Titans in
January 2000 okay so I was having a
decent tournament but you know it's the
last round
I'm not really in prize contention so
let's make sure what color I am though
oh I had white I hear what all right so
so right so it's so this looks like a
friendly tournament a fun tournament but
anyway so I'm out of prize contention I
don't never played this before but
whatever uh play and so the games kind
of silly now I am attacking his Knight
Bishop takes it takes okay so now he
gets tricky takes with the rook because
obviously if I take back with the bishop
he's got check done another check and
then I have the SEC back so that's not
really how the game goes so I see it and
continue on it makes them look for my
king
oh look buddy we got a question in the
audience here what's right I don't
understand work these seven either is
that your question what's the deal with
all right so you've got a check
obviously I have to take back with the
king he gets another check moved my king
away and so now in this kid is like two
hundred points lower rated than me and
he offers me a draw
and I'm like well the Super Bowls
tomorrow if I would end up losing this
game somehow I'm gonna have a bad taste
in my mouth all day and it's gonna spoil
the Super Bowl so I'm like sure why not
draw so then then I you know I'm like
all right I'm talking some Super Bowl
talk with my buddies or whatever and
then there's kids like all like
red-faced they're all mad and then his
dad comes up to me and like you know it
was just he was just offering the drove
because you know you know it's just like
his psychological way you know it's like
dude it's not my problem you offered the
draw you know it's like we're not gonna
reset up the board and play from there
like he pretended like you
offer the draw it's like you're offered
the draw so so if you offer a draw don't
be shocked if they take it got it all
right all right so we got to show the
famous of all famous games is everybody
ready for this one
No yeah yeah I wouldn't be either you
might want to get refill on the popcorn
and soda for this one because this is
we've already gone over this one with
the chair but it's just it's just too
good it's too good to be true right this
is like one of the most famous games of
all time
it's between comer and the guy in the
chair but the guy is not here tonight
unfortunately he's seen the videotape
sorry
so I have the white pieces so you should
always be playing before move one so I
am this is where this is the night
tournament so so this is a you pretty
much knew the parents like a week before
now this guy had white in round one okay
and then requested a half point by so
then he thought that he should get white
in the third round as you know he
skipped his black but that's not the way
chess works you know if if you play what
you play alternating things so just cuz
you skip a week doesn't mean you're
automatically get the color the same
color again does that make sense
all right so he tries to sit down as
white anyway I'm like get over there all
right
so here we go so I'm in no mood to back
up all right so we're playing
psychological so so not the best opening
ever but whatever now I play a good move
here believe it or not anybody see a
good move
nope yeah try again deep yeah all right
so I'm attacking his queen he moves it I
Castle and now I play the best move of
all time I know some people have seen it
it's like it's like shaking your fist
right at home what is it you might have
had it did he say it on accident a Bobby
Fischer moment you've seen this game you
how could you not remember this game
every other move is is good for black
Erik you just saw this like a week ago
oh you know the answer yeah I want to
hear from Nike just copied off a test no
but it's not clean a floor no that's you
should know who you're copying off of to
when you're the gern Stein to say it
even though he's seen this probably 500
times aren't adjourned go ahead say it
Bishop d8 double X clam so the point is
I'm attacking his undefended night and
I'm threatening a move like Knight to g5
and I get that pleasure of just slamming
the bishop right down there so so he's
like this this is another thing you do
in chess alot psychological
when somebody like hurts you you want to
hurt them back as we'll see later in
this game so he now he's threatening a
fork so if you have a plan just go with
it no matter what
really
no matter what queen so he takes my rook
I'm gonna take his rook and now I should
just play Queen takes f1 and then just
be so happy but I decide to do it again
where wait you can't take my bishop you
can't take my bishop because if he takes
my bishop
I play Queen f7 check he moves the King
I take the bishop with check he moves
this King and then I take his Knight two
for one
so you can't take me you can't take me
and obviously what move can black play
now to really infuriate white yeah I'll
give you a hint I'm threatening King
takes f1 yeah Alex cool you should get
this come on
thank you alright so now I can't take it
no I'm mad alright but I do play the
best move somehow big check so I take
hand so now I get my emotions the best
of me so he plays a blunder here but I
can't capitalize on it oh yeah so okay
so well maybe not my blunder yet so King
f8 so if you ever have the pleasure of
coming down to the st. Louis chess club
and get to play me in a game of blitz so
I'm a trash talker okay but the reason
why I trash talk is because I'm so in
the game so focused so everything okay
so so he plays King f8 why did he play
King f8 to just to try and come and win
my night on h8 right so I play be six
right so why did I play e6
exactly because I want to play Knight f7
and yeah right this guy he wrote yeah
it's like what was the point of that
it's like in you just let me do it yes
all I would has just been all over him
if we would have been able to talk so
now he's h6 and I and I play here and
just goading him just goading him to
play g5 just goading them and of course
guess what
so unfortunately I'm like you play g5
you play g5 I'm just gonna take it I'm
just gonna take it so he does it and
instantly I just take it what moves
should I buy a played here
Knight takes h6 check right and game
over but I got the got the best of me
all right so take stakes oh so now he's
so offended that I took his pawn so
instantly so instead of just taken back
like any normal person
he's just only so mad because he didn't
understand that that was a blunder yet
so he's gonna capture my pin piece just
the satisfaction of saying check all
right
I'll hope it was worth it buddy all
right so I take so now he takes I take
and so now here he goes his bishops is
under attack
help mm what move does he play yeah
let's say he plays Knight to d2 so that
takes check I move he takes rook attacks
the night so now like I have one way to
win I mean what's the only way in the
world white can win this game okay yeah
you're right on both counts right what
and what of all the pawns
if it was my move let's say it was my
move what of all the pawns in the world
has the best chance of promoting the a
pawn right the one that's farthest ahead
to away if that doesn't get your head
going like oh my God he's two away from
queenie with a check I don't know what
does okay so so eliminate the guys
threat instead check it's like good eye
what my king up there he's like check
that's like dude you just gave me you
had a chance to take it and you blew it
now what should we make our king or war
you're right am I afraid of this
discovered check no it's like yeah check
me check me now I won't I won't give you
the satisfaction it's like fine alright
now I give him a powerful check what's
the difference between his checks and my
check what kind of checks I I did not
I've never used the word thank you check
in my life but alright but look look his
checks were making my King walk way up
there my check is get in the corner
yeah and that's where he belongs right
alright so here I come so here he comes
and now I think oh man I did I'm great
I'm great I'm great I'm threatening
Knight check everything's great and then
he makes a great move and now I'm like
oh my god
now he just stopped my little check and
is attacking on f3 his check it's not
like oh my god how am I gonna blow this
game so so just go for it sometimes when
when you're down in there and things are
looking at their worst just go for it
don't be like Alex go and just walk out
the door and just say oh no no no like I
can't bear to watch you got to just go
for it so if you were gonna go for it
what move would you make here I always
hear from Felix hein yes thank you all
the guy had to do what what's what's the
promotion Square yay
just get your rock on EA and you'll have
no trouble at all but nope
I got to get behind the C pawn yeah
that's gonna really help you out that
c-pawn he's so right
he plays rook c8 and then I just
calculate it I'd like if you lost you
lost you lost so hopefully everybody
else can be as good as being calculate
out the next 20 moves so I'm like and
this is when you want to stop it all
right great
you always want to slam your pieces when
you know you've won because if you slam
it too quick then they might be like oh
I'm on to something no it's guys really
serious but now if you do it when you
won it's like right oh yeah he is
serious and there's nothing I can do
boom it's over if his rook was on e
eight it would be a draw but d2 I'm like
I knew you were gonna play that nobody
cares what do I play here do you think I
play a check yeah rook d6 thing right
yeah little late buddy
little little late I'm getting a call
from my boss hey quit making fun of this
guy in the chair already he already did
this program all right yeah whatever so
and so I can still blow it here what's
the losing move for white here rook e8
right I do not want to play rook d8 here
even though it looks good it's too
complicated it's too complicated
I'm not calculating that out yeah yeah
once you find a solution even if it
takes 15 moves if you calculate on your
brain stop looking for a shorter path
you're just going to confuse yourself
okay so once you've got a win you see
the win
implement the win all right
what's up six you just let the guy in
the chair off the bat
look at this King up six he doesn't even
want to go desk thanks a lot
thanks a lot I might even lose here now
did I look oh I wouldn't lose because I
would I would be too smart I wouldn't
take the rook I would not give to in
this position if he played if I of
course I did not play King up six in the
game King e6 actually does lose the game
King f6 draws the game because I have
one move to play fine if you really want
me to give a check first just like the
man let them out of the corner for no
reason fine okay so so obviously I play
in this position anybody going once
going twice
rook takes d2 right
check check
should I take the pawn no predictor look
and then give the guy no hope so what's
the move that gives the guy no hope just
crush his soul yeah
nope nope
Alex goooo no a4 good a4 go go just go
at playoff the game Tim no
all right page four right way better Oh
King g8 what's he trying to do where is
he trying to go this is the best route
this this would just make the guy why he
doesn't resign but he might as well
Brooke
yep yeah you're never getting past here
you can't do it and then I can just run
it you can figure out how to win this
game from here okay please no no so
that's how I beat the guy in the chair
that one day alright so you want to end
on that high note or do you want to want
to see one more quick one one more yeah
all right all night long alright alright
so here we go this we got about two
minutes left
alright so this is a team tournament
from January 1999 alright so I'm still
in the I'm still in the zone alright so
I playing a guy rate at 700 so team
tournaments are a lot of fun because you
know there's camaraderie and you know
it's just a lot of fun so so this is
this is another way you can win a game
so playing is nights out of the way so
I'm crushing on up crush you know just
try to trade off everything threatening
checkmate
what should you play here to stop
checkmate orange guy h6 you know what
other move stops checkmate rook e8
so now this is what move should you play
here it's actually I was like okay I got
your queen but he tricks me so I take
his queen but he gets my queen here we
go
all right King f8 we've seen this before
Kings trying to hunt down the night
right
so how should I try to stop him from
getting King takes Knight and don't
Outlook on your phone for the answers
okay it's pretty simple our feelings
just give them the night horrible Bishop
c4 wonderful but this guy's like not so
fast now what yeah Bishop b5 so I've
want to make him escape
no he tries again it's like get off that
diagonal I'm like it's not that easy
rook attacks my poem I defend it but
removes the defender but I get his D
pawn so it all equals out real attacks
the bishop
so I could just play Knight c3 here but
I take first oh I couldn't a play Knight
c3 here maybe well maybe I could have
been psychological right yeah you never
know he would never know
so Bishop attacks now I'm playing in a
team tournament so look this guy he's
like me is he he doesn't want to resign
right he likes the play on forever and
ever and ever so if you're a kid you
could pie still get away with this okay
so this is the most satisfying move in
chess when somebody makes a move to like
protect a pawn or protect the square and
then you just do it anyway and I've just
laugh and laugh and laugh and laugh and
laugh and this guy's got all big he's
like so excited so excited I'm making a
comeback
not really kid so I'm just laughing and
laughing and laughing his dad's looking
at me like what are you doing it's like
I gave a high-five to my teammate and
then after rook takes he's like well
I'll protect the C pawn and I'm like kid
just give it up and then Boop resigned
so that started my like 19 game win
streak to start out 1999 so that was
another good year for Michael J comer
hopefully you learned a lot about
psychology chess what you should do what
you shouldn't do get your mind set be
playing before move one play to win the
game be talking like even if you can't
trash talk they have a constant you know
stream of thought with yourself and
figure out what's going on and hopefully
you don't have to read books you don't
have to study forever you could just win
with the mind games buddy alright yeah
go ahead
you
[Music]